hello
today i will present the foreseer
a data analysis and report generation
application
fully based on wall from technology
because data analysis is so fundamental
for supporting decision making processes
we have created and we carefully
customize deforester
to analyze our customers data and to
generate
meaningful reports such that
standardized information become
always available to key decision makers
without the need
of a team of analysts in their
organization
let's explore the foreseer what you will
see here
is a demo version of the forseer created
to show how different types of analysis
can be performed on a single instance of
default seer
pointing to different data sources
okay so let's get started so
if we type here e
commerce analysis which is one of the
types of analysis that has been said
we will see how the system
generates a standardized report
this report contains sales
cumulative sales by countries
per product line and also a map showing
where the sales have occurred
with colors pointing or somehow
associated to the
amounts so also we have here
in the data of the pivot analysis made
under this analysis
that's only one standardized
report we are going to go through many
and many more details
if we also go to another report
for example frame printing product sales
timeline
we will see similar uh
analysis this one only pointing here
to the somehow stuck bar
chart showing the sales by country by
different
dates so so far we have seen
two different analysis pointing to
two different data sets um
see also it is important to say
that um this system uh
provides like a flavor of first of all
of the data that
has been used for the analysis uh here
is
what was selected by default like the
bar chart and we have a map for the
sales
record and then we have like the pivot
analysis pointing and they are showing
is playing uh like sales per
um dating country and we also have like
a combination
of the three um
displays that we showed before this is
just
one potential way of using
or creating a report let's take a look
at another one
okay here we'll go um
to a favorite that was previously
set and we are pointing now to a
different data set
and we will see the schools in puerto
rico where
the entrance enrollment or total student
students
um in each school
is less than 100 and the results are b
are going to be displayed by town so
here you have
a map of
showing the towns where those schools
are
and some information uh on the exact
locations
where the schools are
another example we could show here i
mean we can go to a
menu here actually all of the
reports can also be selected in that
menu
so here you have a similar um
analysis or you know this one is based
on another data set
and um of course you have a different
analysis this is
this for information here we have like
different
products that are also sold together and
associated with their frequency for
example
a short bermuda and a top t-shirt and
that happens
126 times on the data set that was
analyzing here we we can have some sort
of you know
create that information here
so uh that was just uh you know a quick
introduction
let's just go to the details
of this um
analysis for example um
so um
first of all as we said before we have
the different
uh types of uh
components of the report right we have
the data we have
predictions which we will see shortly we
have
this stack bars we have a map
we have the output data and we have
the combined report now
uh it's important to say that we can
also use natural language processing
to um ask specific questions here so
the standard reports but you can also
come here
and for example select this
example which created
a particular setup for us
and in this particular setup as you can
see
um there has been a particular request
right so we want sales for the top two
product names from this date to this
another date right so uh we can change
just
to let you see we can change the date
here
uh for another month and we will see
the system creating the report for us
or updating the report for us um
in the same way we can you know go
and take uh another example for example
this
example where uh we are
particularly particularly um
pre-selecting uh the countries where we
want the analysis performed
and we want the analysis in this case
made for the last six months
so um once we have done that it's
important to say that you have the
capability
of exporting your report in different
formats
um just as an example if you reported
png
of what we are just showing here
um this is a png which you could use for
whatever purpose you have in mind and
also you can
here uh export um
an excel file with the um
the information for the
um people analysis details
so um so there you have the capability
of exporting
your analysis it is also possible that
some people
want to go into more details and for
that we have this
left pane here with uh many options for
advanced users to go and make changes
just as an example here we can go to the
quantity ordered
here uh to make a filter on the quantity
holder order
and uh let's say that we want um
uh the quantity order to be
less than or equal to 30.
we do that and we update the report and
there we have
the results and um of course
i didn't show i mean the target is up
here we could also
change the target and what's the
summarizing function there are so many
things that you can
change and um
something else you could do is um
besides the filters
is that um you i mean the filters on
whatever variable you want in
that data set you can um modify the
filter
on the dates you have calendars here
with whatever did you
select the big dates and make
whatever selection you want and then
um you can also use
um the people chart controls and then
let's say that you won't see uh
a date uh
uh plot uh dateline plot
of your results then you get this i mean
it's
fairly detailed maybe and if it's too
complicated something we could do is
just for example let's remove the
country
and then i have a more beautiful
output here so uh as you can see there
are many
many uh things that you can do
in this uh left pane to modify
your um
setup to get whatever analysis you have
in mind and always
uh whenever you are doing this all of
the components
of the analysis are being created for
you
okay in defaults here you can also make
predictions and for example
in the e-commerce analysis example
we have created ways to do predictions
and what we will have to do here
is um first of all take into account
that
there's a time period um
control that will be used for the
predictions
uh and also a filter for
for debates um we can just set up the
system for making the predictions we
select a method
let's method for creating the model
using the function
predict of the workflow language let's
select random forest
and the performance let's go to hike as
possible quality and
all we have to do is to click on create
the model
will be created for us once the model is
created
um we could take a look at the details
of the model
uh but let's leave that for next time
and uh let's just go and score
the data okay so we're creating the
predictions now
and let's expand our dates uh
a little bit further such that the date
fielder filter
allows to see the predictions now when
we analyze again
we will see the
predicted values for
two months the time periods as we wanted
for the product line said
or the categorical variable in this case
product line that we had selected
and our same as uh
with any other analysis we could go and
hear for example make a
line chart or a date list plot of
the analysis and
um defaults here can also be used for
other things than
uh customizing it for your analysis
it can also be used as a
way to portray things that you've done
in the past and
in for example here um
we have set up some of the examples on
the
well from the welcome demonstrations
project
uh just to show you that um
[Music]
you could for example bring your own
demonstrations um
[Music]
or just for whatever performance
whatever you want to do it
but several of your
let's say you want to take a look at
the foot and just you know
those are the demonstrations and the
work from
uh demonstration side that's what our
work
we're just demonstrating that whatever
work you've done
that could be uh say using dynamic
modules for a
you know a way that it is self-contained
we could bring it here
important than that is that you can also
analyze your data so
we have ways to explore
your data set so you just
type explore data set you either
select a table from a
database or an excel file
or some other form of data let's in this
case
pick this um
example dataset when we do uh on
spreadsheet files and we use
input the sheets we then select the one
that we want to
take a look at the data has been
imported
and uh you have some information here
telling you which are the column names
that were imported uh
whether there's there's a date column in
this case pregnancy date
which are the numeric columns and the
categorical columns so
those that can be used for creating
group analysis
and um once you've
imported your data you can go ahead and
go and analyze
it's going to be really simple analysis
because the
default setup is simple but the the idea
is that
a a target response has been selected
for you and target
summarizing function has been served for
you
and then all you have to do is for
example to
define some filters
[Music]
you can for example filter
on this variable to be
born alive is whether the animal was
born alive
on this data set we want for it to be
for example
greater than zero and then um
analyze again basically it's going to
provide you the same information
because of how the data was created um
and then uh we we could go and uh for
example
uh create a filter on the pregnancy date
and we may want to for it to be
[Music]
after for example uh
the first of
january
thousands and uh
once you observe that filter you could
also
uh for example create a
plot of a line plot
of dates and there you will have uh
a simple display of the
birds animal birds in this dataset
and um you to just to make
the analysis more interesting
um you can group by let's say by colony
and then in this colony select which
colonies you want to be
displaying on the analysis
there you go we have this um
take into account that this is a data
set i know but
don't forget that this is this could be
done with any
data set i mean this is not something
that we had prepared beforehand it's
just
any data set as long as it has
meaningful data
and it is structured as a rectangular
array with headers
we can just bring it in and do some
analysis
with it so and of course uh
once the analysis is done you can do all
the exporting
and and of the output and you have
several
um you know uh type of some
types of output and everything has been
set up there
for you so in conclusion
uh what we have demonstrated
is that defaults here is a data analysis
and report generation system
created using the warfarm language to
take advantage of the work from language
extensive
extensive library of functions for
analytics
prediction models image processing and
symbolic processing
it is provided as a stand alone
applications
so users don't actually need to have
mathematica that's something we could
talk
later on we carefully customize defaults
here
to analyze customers data and generate
customized reports so
the main features is that this is a
multi-platform
application windows mac and linux
because it's based on
natural language uh on the webcam
language it also provides non-pro
language processing
you can select set favorites i didn't
demonstrate that quite well but you can
set your favorites
you can export png excel
and you can do pivot analysis and
categorical data analysis
you can import data from spreadsheets
databases
or other work from language reported
data
sets and
it's important to emphasize the default
sphere
is capable of handling different data
sources
in parallel such that
all of your analysis can be done in the
same platform
at the same time and you will always
have
standardized analytics predictions
and reports for you and
for your organization by means of using
the foreseer
you